sam are you still there
all right i'm not sure how many people
are watching this but we got
kicked off up one zoom and we are now
trying to make it work on another zoom
channel
and hopefully my colleagues will get
back on
although anything goes because it's been
a very crazy
uh years everybody knows and uh
all the more so with the wildfires that
are occurring
here in jackson wyoming so i've got two
live streams right now
i'm going to put a link to the
shareable account here i'm going to view
live on youtube
and see if anybody's there and hopefully
my co-host will join
very soon my guest will join very soon
and i see some of us are there
and hopefully it came
up started streaming 62 seconds ago
so hopefully that works there i am okay
so we are now waiting for
our other guests to show up maybe they
will maybe they won't
we have plenty to discuss regardless
and the only other thing i can think is
that
maybe they are waiting for me
in the zoom room but this doesn't look
particularly
promising so let me see if they will
come on
we have 91 watching now
let's all get edited out don't worry
um let's see got an error message
all right um
let me see about this that
i'm going to invite
here invite
sam singer who is the
proprietor of my own stargazing
copy invite link and here we go
um let's try this
okay so now this should work
and we will get some lovely guests
joining us
i want to just say how cool it is to be
able to see and use
this enormous telescope facility even in
the midst of this corona
plague that we are all experiencing
we're in
all international astronomical star
parties have been
cancelled sadly but
fortunately we have the ability to
connect virtually and i think that's
quite spectacular so let me see if my
friends can get in
and hopefully we'll be able to go live
there um let's see we got him that's
live
and here we go so i am going to
check out
the star images
that i have obtained from this telescope
good all right
good so i have a set of images that we
are going to go over
and i'm going to share them with you and
again this is celebrating a couple
things one is celebrating
the um first example of
the hubble telescope's major
contributions
to astronomy and i think the best place
to start with that is one of hubble
himself edwin hubble's first
spectacular images that really set the
world
aflame if you will to really demonstrate
for the first time
that we were an island universe within a
much much larger universe
and here is an image taken by a
composition
of images taken by um
taken by the hubble space telescope
and this phenomenal image
has really revealed in startling relief
the glory of what hubble himself first
kicked off
about uh 97 years ago in 1923 hubble
discovered a cepheid variable which is a
pulsing star located somewhere around
here
in the andromeda galaxy which he
initially mistook for
a simple nova that is a flaring star
that goes on and off of regular
periodicity that henrietta
swan levitt had determined could be used
as a type of ruler that we could use to
measure all the way out to the hubble
uh to the uh to the andromeda galaxy
which is located about three million
light years away from earth
and by counting the the pulsations if
you will
and uh observing in this you know
phenomenon
over the period of october of 1923
hubble was able to determine that this
was actually located at tremendous
distances
much farther than the unknown extent of
the milky way galaxy
because of that uh hubble was able to
establish once and for
all the answer to the question uh
whether or not the milky way
is a galaxy or whether or not it was the
entire universe and that was the subject
of what's called the great debate
so some of these images were taken with
with hubble and some of the next images
i'm going to show you were taken by
mike adler's camera this is a nebula
this is a raw
image made from relatively long exposure
um and that exposure there's mike coming
in now
hi mike can you hear me i can
great so we're reviewing on the screen
and now wow
yeah one of your images that you took i
think this
is this the veil nebula which nebula is
this no this is the uh bubble nebula
uh and uh it's um a very interesting
nebula because uh it
uh it's uh surrounded by hydrogen gas in
fact this is a bubble
of hydrogen gas being essentially
inflated by the stock bright star right
here
and samuel will have a a series of
pictures of this
uh nebula uh that are done in uh
different ways for example there's a uh
a a uh narrowband image
in the hubble palette which will be
largely green
uh so i don't know samuel you want to
show that
yeah yeah i mentioned about
20 seconds and mike are we able to look
at the look through the telescope
currently at jupiter or saturn or is it
well
i was uh i was looking at it earlier and
it just looks
very faint i don't i don't think it's
bright enough to actually show up
tonight so sam first why don't you show
the image of the before and after the
current uh quad state area wildfires
uh that would be a cool image to show
yeah let me uh share my screen
once i get that image up and yeah
all right one sec hey tony are you back
yeah we're back and um
i need to turn on my video
sorry about that brian did mean to mess
it up for everybody it's okay
um not a problem tony we are really
sorry here's what we're working with
tonight folks
on the left is uh generally the view of
the mountains uh out in kelly wyoming a
few miles from where i live and on the
right
is a picture that was
taken just about an hour ago hour and a
half ago
so you can see we are pretty socked in
with smoke
from mostly the california fires right
now um some in idaho as well but
um the prevailing winds just bring the
smoke from the west
right over those mountains and settles
in the valley
yeah i came to escape the uh the
wildfires but
uh it's not uh not working out for me
unfortunately
you've escaped the fire but not the
smoke that's right
how far away are the fires
800 000 miles away you know but
okay so these are the fires from
california then not not fires there in
wyoming there's a fire yeah
utah i've heard that's right fire in
colorado oh okay i thought these were
fires in the states so this is
this is the stuff that's happening a
thousand miles away yes
because colorado's in wyoming usually
get really bad this time of year as well
there's a fire in pocatello area but
that's not what's bringing most of the
smoke this is the
amazing fires in california okay all
right
unfortunately this is a phenomenon this
is pretty bad this is about as bad as
i've ever seen it but
um we often get smoke this time of year
uh unfortunately because of wildfires
unfortunately the one year that was an
exception to that
was three years ago for the eclipse
it was a perfectly clear blue skies this
week
in fact tomorrow is the uh the three
year anniversary of the eclipse
and it was just crystal clear so
we got we got one great august when we
really needed it
yeah boy that would have been a total
loss we had totality in jackson so
it was pretty awesome but two days ago
it was
very clear here too so it was just the
smoke has just arrived
crazy so
um let us take a look we had a set of uh
kind of a schedule that we want to take
folks through tonight
and i think we should go ahead with that
if we can
and maybe we'll use sam's images in case
we
um uh when you share your images sam and
we'll start off what we wanted to do was
kind of
introduce what we were going to um
bill as you know this anniversary of of
two major
important uh events in the history of
astronomy one was the
great debate that set the scale of the
entire universe
uh excising the milky way as the center
and the entirety of the entire universe
and then
that was by discovery of the andromeda
uh galaxies
nebula pulse ah sorry pulsing cepheid
variable that we talked about before you
guys joined
but maybe first we'll go to take a look
at um we're gonna look at saturn and
jupiter
uh do we have any images of those guys
or um
sam did you not include those because i
can bring one up really quickly
yeah if you've got one handy um go for
it but i can i can grab some as well
yeah i have a nice one that's uh yeah i
have a nice one that's a
rotating gif of of the uh
which i was i sent out my email today
to my uh to my viewers to my listeners
um copy image copy that
and i wanna paste it here
so i'm gonna get out of here there we go
so this is a composite set of images
that i turned into a gif
but let me share my screen here
so we wanted to start with jupiter and
actually jupiter is nice because you can
uh you can really see tremendous detail
even with
a telescope on earth but certainly with
the hubble space telescopes can you guys
see that on your screen
okay so this is just one frame which
shows of course the famous gray red spot
down there
but also even through a tiny telescope
galileo was able to glimpse the moons of
jupiter which he called
the medicine stars i always point out he
named
the objects in which he discovered after
the funding agency
that provided the resources to build his
telescope so
maybe we'll call mike's telescope you
know we'll name his discoveries the
ieee or something like that um your
funding agency well most of our spouses
have to be our funding agency they have
to allow us to uh
to spend their money and our kids to
spend their inheritance um but you see
the incredible rich structure
and it was rumored i don't know if you
guys ever heard the rumor that galileo
could
may have spotted the great red spot um
and that dates its age to at least 410
years old
this is the 410th anniversary of the
discovery of
the moons of jupiter and the observation
of jupiter by galileo
which i talk about often as being the
first great debate
the debate that set the scale of the
solar system and displace the earth
from its central location where it had
occupied a position since antiquity
so um you know i think that that's a uh
that's that's quite
an amazing uh amazing accomplishment for
uh
for an italian gentleman of the northern
region of italy
and with a small telescope he was able
to really displace the paradigm that it
held for
literally millennia so uh
sam do you have a picture of saturn that
you can show
i actually have a picture okay i
actually
i don't have a saturn but i do have a
picture of
jupiter from the juno satellite that i
made myself
like green but um i've got that queued
up
but i have to be able to get off of your
screen here
to find it there you go great okay
um i've got it up ready to go mike
okay go right ahead were you thinking of
the uh the south temperate region one
yeah we could do that one first that's
probably the most unique one
great okay
now this picture this picture i'll just
talk a little bit about it it's uh
it's taken by the juno satellite so it's
the first
time that we've ever seen okay well this
is not
okay this is the south temperate region
all right i loved i love these juno
pictures man
well i made i made this picture juno has
left the
uh processing of their pictures up to
amateurs they've decided
they provide the raw pictures and uh
and so this is this was a very difficult
picture to make because juno
goes around the saddle the uh the planet
it gets very close at the equator within
several thousand miles
and then gets uh up to uh uh sixty
thousand miles
at the uh as it's going over the poles
so it has a polar orbit
this was taken this is four separate
pictures taken on a single orbit
from very different different distances
so to make this into a single picture
that captured
pretty much the whole planet uh from
very different distances was not easy
right and you you processed this
yourself i did this
yeah this is my picture i'm going to put
a link in the in the chat
box uh the live chat to where you can
get image processing software
um this is from swri uno
dot edu juno so folks can click there
and they can get um they can try to try
their hand to make an image like that
blue
yeah they can get the raw images right
from the juno's
website and uh as i said this was four
separate images taken at very different
distances
but it's a it's a nice one because it it
captures
the southern hemisphere i think it's
about from 38 degrees south
you can see the giant red spot you could
also see the south pole
which again uh a viewpoint that we've
never seen before
until the juno satellite but you can
just see that from emerging detail
in the uh uh in the cloud formation now
this
camera on the junocam is only 2000
pixels by 2000 pixels
but it's an interesting camera because
the satellite is rotating
while these pictures are taken so it's
uh
the whole process of acquiring pictures
making those pictures and acquiring them
is
not straightforward do you guys know if
the juno cam was it
was it installed on juno kind of as a as
an afterthought or was that
it was done strictly for i think citizen
science right that was its purpose
but they added that it almost seems like
an
afterthought because compared to the
other instruments on the right
this is just a tiny it's a tiny little
camera hung off the side of the
satellite i mean yes i love it
it's the size it's the size of the uh
it's the size of a single lens reflex
camera i mean maybe a little larger
because uh there has some it has some
sophisticated
uh soft uh hardware software to deal
with the fact
that satellite is rotating while it's
taking this picture
it's almost like they built this whole
spacecraft to do this amazing science
and somebody said
hey you know what dude we got to put a
camera on here somewhere
people should be able to see something
yeah they have infrared cameras and
ultraviolet cameras and
you know ways of measuring the ground
and magnetometers and all kinds of stuff
that measure
all these non-optical things but the
thing that people see
uh most notably about this mission are
the fantastic pictures that
people uh you know like myself and
others have
made maybe
there's i'll bring up the south pole
shot now if you want yeah the south pole
shot is
is probably the um uh it's the most
unusual
um you know now there it is so this is
uh
this is the first time ever i mean that
anyone has seen the south pole i mean i
don't mean
this picture but by the juno satellite
and uh
this again was uh this one was difficult
too
because the satellite only captured
about
about a third of the south pole on each
of its orbits
so this was the first third and fourth
orbit that the juno satellite made that
that provided the raw data to make this
picture
and so piecing that together again was
not good
so yeah these are phenomenal um
uh mike do you have any images of saturn
did you say or did sam no i don't
i've got a couple i can bring up okay
yeah sam why don't you
take over so so first here's not a great
image of saturn
this one i took with my droid phone
just holding it up to one of our 20-inch
dobsonian telescopes
uh no tracking nothing like that just uh
holding the droid camera up there and
snapping a picture through uh i think it
was a maybe a 25 millimeter eyepiece
okay just just got the rings
all right we're not seeing are you
showing it try to try it again sorry
you know we're not seeing it yet all
right my bad try it one more time
because i
just allowed you both to be able to
share no i just forgot to uh
tony did you kill the stream on your on
your channel they do on the live stream
people are watching and i'm chatting on
it right now
oh okay cool yeah you guys see that now
yeah
all right so this is the image that i
got with my droid phone
well i gotta tell you that um i um
the pictures that if if it was clearer
tonight the pictures that we would be
seeing
uh uh uh live are about this quality
so it wouldn't have been a lot better
that's not bad though
what what was the eyepiece you had in
there uh it was just a um
uh a need two inch uh super please
and that's probably right that was
pretty good that's my droid
that's my droid camera i mean this is
it took several tries
i was i was going at it for about 20
minutes
the trick was to get it just on the edge
of the eyepiece actually when the image
was centered i couldn't get it right i
couldn't get the the rings to come out
but just on the edge
i could get it pretty good
awesome that oh i'll show you one
that is a pretty incredible contrast
yeah can you guys see that one uh well i
see hubble heritage down the lower right
so yeah
it's quite a bit different yeah you're
not being fair to yourself this is not
the most
this is not my camera phone now this is
the hubble this isn't the most recent
picture
that humble took actually this one was
from a
while back
um the most recent picture i think is
even better because the rings are tilted
at a real nice angle
but i just have to share my favorite
saturn fact
so when we go i'll go ahead mike i was
just going to say the cassini pictures
of saturn though
are are the the most amazing
um anyway yeah
yeah um but when when we're we're out
doing
stargazing programs and you know we have
folks see
saturn for the first time and you know
their eyes kind of pop out of their head
but you know they don't even think it's
real and i joke with them that it's just
a sticker on the end of the telescope
um right but uh what i'd love to tell
everybody about saturn
is that if you had a bathtub big enough
and enough water to fill it you could
stick saturn
in the bathtub minus its rings and it
would float
because it's the only planet that's less
dense than water
that's right right you guys can't see it
in the in the meeting but i'm showing
the latest uh 30th anniversary image of
saturn from hubble
uh awesome it's up there yeah it's
beautiful man it's really great i don't
know man cassini did a good job but
hubble can hold its own for a 30 year
old i'll tell ya
it's it's doing okay i think so yeah
so next up we wanted to take a tour
through
um to look through uh
a couple of other images that have been
extremely important throughout
astronomical history
and let me queue those up here
um so i think the first one we were
gonna do
is to go is to go to
after you know now we're going into the
realm of the deep sky
so we're gonna look at some nebulae that
are
um uh the result of the death of stars
so we're gonna look at life cycles of
stars
we're going to look at some young stars
some old
gray-haired stars and then we're going
to look at some dead stars
in the aftermath of a dead star so i
think the first one we're going to look
at is the very famous ring nebula which
is right overhead probably now
for many of our listeners viewers
etcetera and this is sort of an iconic
and negative saturn just so you know i
mean i can try to point my telescope at
it well there it is
that's a picture from my telescope but i
could try to actually do it if we wanted
to
i'm not sure how well it's going to come
out well that's the actual image i think
that's about as good as we can
frankly uh that's that is the image and
you want to talk about that mike you
want to talk about what we're seeing
there okay well this
this is uh uh as brian was just saying
uh this is the ring nebula which is a
it's called a planetary nebula
because uh it's circular it has nothing
to do with planets however
and it's the remnant of a sun-like star
the sun
is uh burning our sun right now is
burning hydrogen
into helium with the release of energy
once all the hydrogen is gone it's going
to
uh the fires are going to go up briefly
helium that gravity is going to take
over squeeze helium and helium is going
to start a whole new nuclear reaction
but after helium burns out and there's
just left carbon
carbon the mass is not big enough for
carbon to begin another nuclear reaction
the star is going to lose its nuclear
fuel
and it's just going to uh expand
into what's called a uh a planetary
nebula like this
and this one is one much like the sun
will
will develop in about four billion years
so we don't have to worry about it right
away
but you can see this little uh thing in
the middle is in fact a
uh uh it's called a white dwarf it is
not a star that is
uh uh it's not a star that's producing
uh
it is producing light but it's only
because it's extremely hot
and it's it actually is cooling down and
it's very very dense it's uh
much denser than normal matter uh not as
dense as a neutron star
but much more dense than the matter uh
that we're used to
and the cloud around it is the leftover
gas and dust
from the uh from the star and it's huge
i mean
this is probably multiple times the size
of our solar system and that's what's
going to happen to the sun is
it when it finally well in fact before
it even goes into this stage
it's going to become a red giant and and
in its orbit will actually its size will
actually encompass
possibly as far as the earth's orbit so
it will not be very comfortable
uh living here on the planet and insert
in several billion years but um but then
once it finally loses all of its uh the
nuclear reactions end and the
fires go out this is what uh we you know
our star will turn into the planetary
nebula
so now for some old stars um we want to
take a look at something that had a lot
of interest this is a great globular
cluster m13
so sam you want to queue up a picture of
a globular cluster i'll talk a little
bit about it while you do that
and then you can take over the screen so
globular clusters are extremely
important they
really do indicate a great deal of
properties
not only about the stars which they
contain they're kind of like they're
called globs because they're basically
globes of stars with
perhaps hundreds of thousands of stars
within each one
they're kind of like mini galaxies but
they're not massive enough to have
black holes within them we'll talk more
about black holes later
but one of the most important aspects of
these globular clusters is
the way that they're distributed around
the milky way
allowed astronomers for the first time
to triangulate the position of the
center of the milky way
and now originally herschel thought that
the center of the milky way was
centered on the earth and the sun and
that's because of an illusion
caused by dust not unlike the smoky dust
that we're experiencing here in much of
the country
but the center of the galaxy was later
found to be
not located in our region of the galaxy
actually towards the constellation
sagittarius and in a little bit
we'll talk about the center of the
galaxy in sagittarius
and even show some animations of stars
as they fly around the center of the
galaxy
enthralled by the gravitational pull of
the black hole within it
but now i want sam and mike to describe
what we're looking at here
this is the most prominent globular
cluster in the northern hemisphere
this is the hercules globular cluster
brian was talking about the position of
these
objects so they're they're not in the
disc of
the milky way where most the stars are
they're actually
in the upper and lower halos
of the milky way um so this object is
about 25
000 light years away from us um so to
put that in perspective
when the light that you're seeing on
this image that we took
last week hit the detector mike's camera
that light had been
traveling through space since the last
ice age
twenty five thousand years ago so it's
it's way out there
and mike what are those uh these stars
are ancient what are those uh
those vertical lines you wanna describe
yeah they're they're because of the
short exposure that we were doing
and so it's it's an artifact of the
shutter closing and opening
when i take my long pictures that you
know
which are typically on the order of 10
to 20 minutes
you don't see those vertical lines so
it's an artifact
of uh this camera is a
cool uh camera cool meaning it's
actually cryogenically cooled
down to minus 30c um it's not meant for
taking short pictures but
i can take pictures uh as short as about
five seconds
but that's about the time it takes the
shutter to open and close
and it leaves these artifacts and sam
can you say something about the
seeing conditions that one would find
when they come out to visit wyoming
stargazing sometime if they're so lucky
so what's a typical uh observing
condition like here
um so you know seeing refers to the
the turbulence in the atmosphere
and we have some pretty big mountains
just to
the west of us and there's a lot of wind
that comes over the mountains and so
even though we're at a high elevation
the climate is
arid which are great for astronomy and
stargazing
um the seeing conditions um aren't the
best in the world
because of um the wind that comes in
over the mountains
um so i think mike actually calculated
um the best scene
uh that he gets through his uh
telescope which is about a few arc uh
seconds was that right mike
that's right about two and a half arc
seconds yep
and it's not bad i mean i mean no it is
so good
no it isn't and uh you know it's not
always that good
um it gets as you know it might be two
and three times that some bad nights but
uh
this night here was uh well this is i i
should tell you a little bit about these
pictures there
um even this picture um well this
picture is a single picture taking
probably about 10 seconds but the
typical pictures that uh
that i take and that are in uh the the
gallery
in the library for example are hours and
hours in some cases as many as 70 hours
so uh there's uh a lot of pictures and
so i i i cherry pick
i take pictures every night that i can
and i
i assemble the very best ones that i can
uh
and so and i try to obviously pick the
ones that have uh
the good scene where i'm getting several
uh arc seconds of scene
yeah so i think next would be good to go
from these globular clusters that
contain perhaps
you know hundreds of thousands of stars
or you know tens to hundreds of
thousands of stars
and go all the way up to the billions
and hundreds of billions
some say maybe even trillions of stars
uh
located in the great companion galaxy to
the milky way known as andromeda galaxy
and so uh sam if you want to take a look
at that
and cue that out and i'll say a little
bit more about i said some in the
beginning
when i was all alone flying solo when
you guys abandoned me
uh no no i'm just kidding but the
images that we were looking at yeah so
is this a hubble image sam or is this
is this a mike adler image
this is a mike adler image that's
amazing i thought it was a hubble
i'm sorry yeah so i was describing
that this is the 100th anniversary of a
great debate
which would have been settled if an
image like uh this by mike had been
available a hundred years ago
of course it wasn't and furthermore it
was the
real subject of the great debate whether
or not this was a spiral nebula
located in the milky way and i often
point out you know things like comets it
wasn't known in the time of galileo
it wasn't known of comets and meteorites
were basically two different sides of
the same phenomenon
namely that comets were an atmospheric
phenomena
and galileo had some speculations in one
of his
great books called the assayer is really
about that
what is the nature of comets and are
they extra terrestrial in the sense of
you know
outside in the solar system uh and the
debate was a very interesting one uh to
be sure
but the next great debate was this you
know how do we know that we live in a
galaxy and
is our galaxy all there is and of course
by finding
a great uh cepheid variable pulsing on
and off
197 years ago it turns out 1923
hubble was able to establish the
distance ladder that went all the way
out to here
and i just love this image because it
shows so much rich structure it's kind
of like a selfie of what our galaxy
would look like if taken from far away
mike how long was this exposure what
what this was on the order of about 12
hours of exposure and
the camera that took this as i mentioned
is a uh
it's actually a black and white camera
but you take you get a color picture
like this by taking
separate pictures first through a clear
uh
filter and then taking it through our
red green and blue filters
and i might i might take as many as
well in this case it was probably about
30 pictures
uh 10 minutes long each uh through
um through each filter and then you
assemble it into a
color picture like this the uh some of
the other features of this uh
picture well let me just say something
else about this picture in general
uh this is what really got me interested
into doing
astro photography uh i i looked at
pictures
uh you know like this maybe as good
maybe not as good but
i wanted to be able to do a picture like
this and so this is
that's what kind of got me started this
was taken by the way not with the
20-inch telescope this is why
uh you know as uh ryan was saying
aperture fever
uh big telescopes can't take a picture
like this easily
uh this is a fairly large object in the
sky this is like six moon diameters end
to end
and so this is was taken with my
six-inch telescope a refractor
uh at nine hundred millimeter uh and
whereas the big
telescope the 20 inch is 3500 millimeter
four times
you would only get a little piece of
this uh you could
eventually get a picture like this and
it could be fantastic
where you would but you would have to
make probably uh you know
instead of just one 12-hour picture
you're making
uh you know six or seven large pictures
and then trying to
make a mosaic of it but the refractor of
course is an extremely
beautiful instrument it's a it's a it's
uh
a uh and it's it has extremely good
optics and so you've got extremely good
pictures out of it the stars are
just pin pricks and tony are you
familiar with the uh
fat survey p-h-a-t yes
yes it's uh it's uh uh i could pull up
the uh
mosaic that that yeah like 500
um images uh that that hubble took to
put it all together
uh what is it called pan uh yeah i put
it in the chat
it's archive i put it in our chat you
can click on it um
in the chat check your zoom chat i'll
put it in the um
live chat as well it's right there
um and i do i do have
i i'm not sure it's worth it but i do
have uh
samuel asked me if i can put it instead
we were going to try to look at this
tonight through the six-inch telescope
and i do have a picture of what that
would have looked like had we done that
but uh yeah it doesn't look quite as
nice as that nice color
yeah i love this color image uh yeah so
tony will bring up the
uh the fat survey pen
chromatic hubble andromeda
treasury i think is what it stands for
i've got it i've got it up on hubble
site now you guys can't see it but it's
up on the stream
and okay um yeah so actually let me
share mine because like i got it up on
my screen too
oh okay okay good yeah
so let's share that okay
so yeah that pancreatic hubble andromeda
treasury
is this region i'm showing out here the
magenta can you see that sam
yeah yeah we can see it yeah yeah so
this is a huge thing so tony were you at
space telescope when any of this was
yeah yeah they were they were doing it
uh while i was there and um
i would love what i'm i'm gonna talk
about here just a minute i'm just trying
to get the
the there's an image that shows every
single pointing
that hubble took to take that as you can
see in that magenta rectangle that's
there that's all it imaged and
it's interesting because they backdrop
that on a spitzer image of the
of the milky way of andromeda so that's
an infrared
image behind it but uh yeah every single
star
in the the the fat image is resolved
okay and it was um it took uh
several hundred pointings of hubble many
many dozens of orbits
uh to take that thing and it is the
highest resolution
image of the of that section of m31
that exists and if you um
if you go to um the
let me just i'm going to put up my
little thing here that i was showing
so here is the hubble site uh thing of
it and if you click on the image itself
you can get resolutions as you can see
here you can get a tiff and a jpeg image
seventeen thousand by eight thousand uh
or i'm sorry seventeen thousand by fifty
five hundred
of of this region and you can scan it
and there's also um there's also
a uh
thing you can do on on online as well to
take a look at this
but this thing is it seems amazing every
single star in there
can't see it on the stream but you know
you zoom in and you're going to see the
individual stars
in the andromeda galaxy so it's pretty
it's uh it's actually it's actually
pretty amazing so
this is this is a quick image of it here
yeah i should mention that the stars
that are on the lower
part of that and above the part of that
in fact all the stars that you can see
in my image
are not stars in the andromeda they're
stars in our milky way
in front of the andromeda that's correct
that would be
yeah in this image i'm showing here is
these bright these bright stars here
yeah that you're going to see in the
form but what you're saying is though
that the actual
individual stars in the andromeda galaxy
can be resolved
that's what yeah that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah let me try and get that
amazing thing um let me go back to that
let's see if there's an archive of that
there's 23 bricks and each yeah so
do you have a sense of any of the um any
of the
uh yeah here's one with all the pointing
so that did you i would show that yeah
let me share
my screen there shows all these
different pointings i guess there's 26
of them
and uh they're quite you can you can
hardly make out
the you know spiral structure of
andromeda from this
low resolution image but then yeah each
one of these
yeah 74 7 400 exposures taken over 411
individual
pointing so yeah 400 and that as each
pointing is a hubble exposure
so and they covered the core of the
galaxy there too so it's it's just
really fascinating that this galaxy
is so important to astronomy for 100
years uh and the nice
you know connection between hubble's
first target
that really set him on a path to the
fame that he has to garner the name of a
telescope
uh and then to see the amount of effort
by scientists around the world
to go deep and study these uh these
pointings these you know as a treasury
as it's rightfully called is just
phenomenal
so respecting tony's time since getting
late i want to talk about
a galaxy near and dear to our hearts
which is of course
our own galaxy the milky way galaxy so
i'm gonna switch over to a different
uh slide maybe um do we have any images
mike of the of the uh
galactic center a sagittarius a star uh
with your instrument that sam could pull
up no we don't we
we were going to do that tonight but we
obviously we did not
yeah we got smoked out so this is an
extreme
zoom in in two different formats this is
infrared
and it's also an x-ray inset so this is
taking
uh i believe a spitzer and then the
x-ray inset shows the close-up is
basically
all you can see with the light gamma-ray
you know x-rays etc
electromagnetic radiation for now and
that's shown here in this x-ray close-up
let's think about the chomdo satellite
chantry satellite and this shows a
tremendous amount of structure
that's located in something that's so
infinitesimally small
you can't even comprehend it when you
look up if you're blessed to be in a
location that's not under siege by
forest fires
uh you could see the center of the milky
way galaxy in the constellation
sagittarius which has this famous
teapot like asterism that makes it so
noteworthy
and if you zoom in and x-rays you can
see this image and if you go even
further into the center of this and and
you get rid of all the gas and the
glowing nebulosity and even the x-ray
emission
and you look right near the center where
there should be nothing
a i.e a black hole you in fact see
something very interesting
and uh can you guys see this animation
that i'm pulling up
okay so this is made by um a group that
at ucla that's called the keck ucla
galactic center group
and they've been monitoring the galactic
center
monitoring the orbits of stars as they
go around
the putative center of the milky way
galaxy
and there's a whole bunch of a very
interesting structure they've been doing
this for about 20 years there
and you see in the in the lower right
this point one arc
seconds that shows you how fantastically
you know small these these images are
and the resolution that they have to get
really require dramatic advances and
it's called adaptive optics
uh mike you have an adaptive optics
reagan here i do not
yeah so it's really an advanced
technology that uses deformations of
mirrors and
and sort of a flexible wavefront
correction
that allows you basically to remove the
atmosphere of the earth and get images
that rival the hubble telescope right
tony i mean
the seeing of the of these images is
comparable to or better than
the ccd resolution that was placed in
the hubble back in the 90s
so um it's it's really phenomenal what
are you talking about the
adaptive optics on i'm talking about
what is
do you know what the angular resolution
is of the
of the uh yeah no not top of my head no
yeah so pretty good though yeah so andre
i guess who's the leader here she's a
fascinating scientist she's really an
amazing person like
mike she went to mit a small technical
college
uh uh in somewhere in cambridge i'm told
and then she went to cal tech and she's
been in los angeles for a long time she
won a genius grant
i've heard her speak tuan doe might be
watching i don't know
he's a a huge leader of this project
he's very active
also in scientific communication he's a
fellow
and many different postdoctoral and um
astronomical so these
these are friends of mine colleagues
co-workers in the uc system many of
these
jessica liu who's at uc berkeley they do
just
phenomenal um research by basically
allowing the atmosphere to be removed
uh using this very clever technology
that andrea and her group
have really pioneered so by monitoring
the orbits of these stars
you see the absence of a star right here
and that's the
galactic center's black hole which we
call the sagittarius a-star
but these are taking over i think about
20 years and then there are other
objects in here that are labeled like
so2
those are blobs of gas which every so
often get close to the black hole and
get these notices on twitter look out
there could be a big
you know explosion from this gas cloud
as it gets eaten by the black hole at
the center
that's never happened so far but
actually i think i'm covering up here
here's the dates in uh and decimal years
starting in 1995 she started doing this
i remember that and so you get many many
complete orbits which allows you to
identify
the location of what must be found to be
a black hole
by the laws of general relativity
there's no other source that can cause
these behaviors of all these various
stars
to orbit in just this way so something
you can't see with a with an amateur
telescope you can't even see
the hubble telescope it's really only
something that's um
that's possible thanks to these adaptive
optics on large ground-based telescopes
and of course there'll be some new
ground-based telescopes hopefully coming
up in the new decade
including the giant magellan telescope
hopefully the 30 meter telescope
and many others so there's very
interesting science and of course this
black hole
is many tony or sam or mike do you know
how many
solar masses this is it's not as massive
as m87
it's about 500 million uh yeah
so it's uh it's quite massive
and and it will presumably be the next
target of the event horizon
telescope so i'm going to look that up
sam or mike you want to add anything
about this object before we move on to
uh other other aspects of stellar
evolution
i think the only thing i would add it
has not about this at this uh
object but just flashing back to the
andromeda one of the other
amusing things about andromeda is that
the andromeda galaxy in the milky way
galaxy are going to
uh uh actually collapse into a single
galaxy
in about uh four billion years which is
about the same time the sun is going to
wink out too so
it'll be interesting times keep paying
your taxes also also dude i just got to
say
because i said it wrong four million so
four million yeah it's not four hundred
maybe i have four i just gotta correct
myself there sorry so there's m87
uh there which you can see in the uh
spot the spring right sam or
when can we see i think it's in virgo
yeah
we uh we actually took some pictures of
m87
uh a couple months ago during our
virtual stargazing programs it's a bit
too low in the sky
right now but um you can't actually see
the black hole with
mike's telescope with the event horizon
telescope
but we can actually see the uh the
glowing core
of um of m87 um in which the super
massive
black hole resides it has tremendous
jets that stream off
actually far larger i'm told here's an
analogy that i heard in a book by becky
smither
smithers who's dr becky on youtube
who'll be on my podcast this coming
monday or recording on monday
she has a wonderful analogy in her book
um uh recent book
um like space at the speed of light i
think it's called
anyway the book's great i don't remember
the titles very well but she
she basically says if m87 shown here
were a grain of sand the actual black
hole
would be a speck the size of an atom
on this image so this whole galaxy's a
grain of sand
and then the jets which you can only see
just the very very most tenuous outlines
up here
would extend the distance of your palm
so it's just an amazing
way to think about how much power this
black hole has to extend something out
you know a good fraction of millions of
light years
perhaps from its galactic center so i'll
get a picture let me see if i can get
him 87
well brian's doing that i'll just say
one more thing about sagittarius a
uh the cool thing about that is it's uh
although you can't actually see the
black hole that part of the sky is
visible right now
so if you look to the south you can find
the console
relation sagittarius it looks like a
teapot and the
the sagittarius a black hole is um just
up in the right-hand corner of that uh
that constellation so look to your south
on a clear night and uh this summer and
you'll look right in the direction of
our galactic center
yeah so let's uh start coming down
now i want to talk about uh two more
nebulae
uh and then we'll finish up with some
very long exposures because it's getting
very late
for poor tony on the east coast and then
we want to give away our door prizes
so i'll give sam some time for that um
let's talk about the
eagle nebula the m16 messier 16.
um sam do you want to call up uh mike's
greatest hits on that
and i don't know do you actually have
the non-greatest hits you have the
like the real-time exposure from last
weekend's observing
and then i think i think we do okay
great yeah i'd love to see
i've got the color one right here mikey
you have the black and white one um okay
i was wondering about um i can know i
can produce a black and white one
uh quite easily um while you're doing
this so
uh let me uh
do that why don't you show the color
picture and uh
well
here's the color shot of the eagle
nebula and uh
in the center you've got the the famous
pillars of creation
made famous by a picture from the hubble
space telescope
um i guess over 20 years ago right tony
yeah yeah 1995 was the first one yeah
25 years ago yeah yeah it's funny how it
became iconic with hubble it was
i guess it was one of the first ones
where people just saw an image from
hubble and whoa
yeah and so he hubble also took a
picture
in 2014 too so with uh
uh it looked quite similar but if you
looked at it in detail you could
actually see differences
yeah and so those pillars are several
light years long right five
five light years yes so 30
trillion miles long those pillars
and that's where we get stars um these
emission nebula
are the the stellar nurseries of our
galaxy and of of every galaxy um
stars are born out of these collapsing
gas clouds
yeah if you want to at some point uh you
want to uh i have a picture of uh
of what it looks like through a through
the telescope what we would have seen
tonight had we looked
yeah yeah let's look at that because i
think you know people get a little
spoiled
when you see things like this which is
the result of
68 hours of exposure this this is not
the 68-hour
print though uh oh no samuel do you have
that one
i do we can get to that in a minute but
yeah let's do that the black and white
okay black and white so you have to um
um yeah
can i share my screen yeah
okay okay so here's my screen
and so here it is uh so this is uh like
a
20-second picture of um uh
of the eagle nebula and i can blow it up
a little bit
um
so you can see the same features that we
were just looking at
and uh
and uh but so this is 22nd picture uh
but to get the detail
um that you saw in the previous one and
one that
samuel will show which was my 68-hour
picture what i did was uh
that picture that samuel showed was
probably on the order of
20 15 to 20 hours of exposure
you know that and it's also done in
narrowband
um to capture the the detail
uh which uh shows a mission of just
hydrogen
in that picture the green was hydrogen
gas
the blue was oxygen gas and the reddish
color was from sulfur this is actually
just a picture
of the hydrogen emission itself alone
in in black and white and that's what we
would have seen pretty much tonight
you can see the other major feature this
is called the uh
this is the pillars of creation but this
is also called the ferry
of the uh which is another amazing
picture there's some beautiful hubble
images
of the ferry of the uh of the
uh of the of
this nebula as well
uh let's see you were asking me earlier
uh
since we're on my screen let me show you
a few pictures
this was a picture of the uh of the
uh m57 uh the
nebula that we looked at earlier uh and
this is more of a process picture you
can see it's in color
and uh you can see a little more detail
it's not just a white ring
there's actually detail in that ring uh
and so this this is uh
a process uh picture of that and the
last one i was gonna show
is what we would have seen had we looked
at the
uh andromeda through my telescope this
evening
my six-inch telescope but this is an
image from my six-inch telescope
of the andromeda and you can see you
can't see all that wonderful detail
that we could see in the finished
picture but you can see we would have
seen
uh these bands just like this we've seen
uh
the uh the spirals uh in in the uh
galaxy itself and this is another galaxy
and this is another gala these are
satellite galaxies
of the andromedas yeah
yeah those are also in orbit around uh
around the uh the center of presumably
the black hole that lies at the center
of the
andromeda galaxy of course we're not
seeing most of what's there
actually most of what's there is dark
matter uh that's really making up
you know five or six times the amount of
the luminous matter that we can actually
see in images like this that's the
result of conversion of
of uh uh nuclear material into heavier
nuclear materials again the fusion
process
um speaking of dark matter i know uh
that you have a picture of the whirlpool
galaxy
m51 which we had hoped to see maybe sam
you can call that up
and then that'll kind of take us home uh
while mike maybe gets his last
image the long exposure of well samuel
has that one so i'm going to let you
okay
yeah great if he has that right away we
can show that now if not
um i've got a i've got m51 up first and
then
okay sure
so there's the whirlpool galaxy m51
it occurs to me that we've we've
mentioned numbers with the letter
m in front of them a couple times
tonight but maybe we haven't uh
explained what that m means and maybe
some people don't know the them stands
for messier
he was a french astronomer who was
obsessed with finding comets
but he created an incredible catalog of
all the
fuzzy spots in the sky that turned out
not to be comets
and so we uh we have his legacy the
messier catalog
of 110 of the brightest fuzzy spots in
the night sky which include
um almost all of the objects we've
looked at so far the ring nebula
um the eagle nebula um the andromeda
galaxy
the hercules globular cluster and now um
the whirlpool galaxy so it's um his
legacy that um
we have this great catalog of all the
bright fuzzy spots to look at
up there in the sky
mike do you want anything about m51 well
m51 is an interesting galaxy it's one of
the iconic galaxies everyone who
has a telescope has to take a picture of
this because it's so beautiful
um and there are two galaxies here
actually
there's a this galaxy here is a separate
galaxy
and is rotating around this galaxy it
also stretches
m51 out so it's more length it's long
it's more long than it is wide and it
eventually will merge
with uh m51 in probably uh
maybe under a billion years unlike the
what i was describing earlier when the
andromeda and the milky way merge now
they're much further apart than these
two are
uh we're two and a half uh million light
years apart
and then so it's going to take four
billion years for that merger to happen
but uh these are going to happen this is
going to happen much sooner than that
again keep paying your taxes out there
everyone
so the last one yeah let's look at that
long exposure image of m16
and then uh tony maybe you have a few
final words before we let you go to bed
and
tuck in your night cap yes i'm not that
tired
okay i can keep going these guys
asteroid hunters on twitch is like
tony's like tony's ready to pack it in
i'm just
listening i'm just he's just chilling
yeah actually yeah do you have any
questions on your channel
uh tony that you wanted no people to
just chat with each other and just kind
of enjoying this joining the
blue picks so yeah yeah
everybody's loving these images mike
these are just phenomenal some are
comparing it my friend uh miguel yeti
tears is talking about how these are
you know kind of the art of the cosmos
god's art almost it's just so phenomenal
that you're able to make these images so
yeah let's
uh what are they what are we looking at
now guys i see the ring nebula again
they're both the ring nebula oh
yeah this is the ring nebula pretty much
the one we were looking at had we looked
at it
through the telescope tonight uh this is
it is just this
type of image we would have seen yeah
and you can see the center star
and you can uh which is the uh white
dwarf
you can see another star uh there and
here this is a
a 70 hour exposure of this
and you can see that it's a flower you
know and it extends way beyond
so there's a uh there's a lot more to
this
nebula than is visible through with the
naked eye
or even even really fairly long
exposures
uh 10 hour exposures you won't see
this uh these double ring of beyond
yeah these are all shockwave and
turbulent phenomenon the different gas
layers which are the result of the last
stages of the
of the uh the explosive end of this star
as a as a nova
shedding its outer outer layers um and
this beautiful cascading
turbulent flow uh so rich in structure
that's really cool yeah you can see it
you can see the two stars
uh in that image very clearly and
they're illuminating
uh with different colored photons and
you can see even
like a very thin shell of violet which
is just
spectacular yeah so in this atomic
colors here that red is uh
ox is hydrogen that violet is uh coming
from
oxygen and the uh uh and
there's a green tinge to this uh out
here makes it all look orange
that's sulphur amazing
so by the way you can see this little
guy up here too this is a
this is another galaxy that's way off in
the distance i have
no idea how far away it is oh wow
it could be hundreds of uh millions of
lights it's
photobombing the ring nebula wow i've
never noticed that wow
certainly never seen it with my uh my
two inch diameter mead telescope
um so sam why don't you show us the last
image of the night with very long
exposure image i believe
of the eagle nebula pillars of creation
and then we'll close it up you know i i
think this was the long
uh 68-hour exposure that mike had for us
mike did you have
a long one of eagle as well oh yeah of
course i
i thought i did send that to you but um
yeah i can uh i can bring that
up um so you're gonna have to let me
share my well
let me just share now okay very good uh
i'm going to um i just have to bring up
uh i have
have the uh yeah that was um
that image there was about 70 hours it's
my uh absolute longest uh uh image
and uh obviously not all at once it's
broken up
i did all one yeah needless to say not
at one night uh i
these are in fact that image i started
taking
image pictures of the m57 probably three
years ago
and what i did this year is i added
probably 40 more hours to it which
allowed me to see
uh that that that large that
way out on the outer edge and uh i'm
just going to uh
yeah tony how does it compare with the
uh hubble ultra deep field of deep field
do you ever
recognize i think those are about 100
hours
hubble typically does 100 second
exposures
um and uh the
well depends on which which deep field
you're talking about they've taken a lot
of them now
um but they it depends on how many
orbits like frontier fields just took
six more hubble b
fields um which i don't have the numbers
off top my head but
uh we're talking in in about 100 second
exposures each
and a 90-minute orbit is when they're
allocated observing time so they build
these up
you know over weeks and weeks um so i
it just depends i don't know i think the
first hubble deep field was
the equivalent of 10 days of exposure
time 11
yeah that's right it was taken between
december that one i was going to talk
about when i leave
yeah it's december 18th to the 28th of
1995. yeah
yeah so it was yeah it was taking over
11 days
and the image is less than spectacular
i'll show it in a bit well okay you'll
show it now
um and uh yeah that's my favorite hubble
image right
it's not the most beautiful it's not the
it's not
even close but it's when you look at
that image
and understand that when they took it in
1995
they did not know that they would see
anything at all
this was pointed at a region of the sky
where they did not
know anything to previously exist and
the field of view of bubble
is so narrow that if you hold it's like
holding
a grain of sand in your fingers held out
at arm's length
that's how much of the sky hubble
subtends so
it sees tiny areas of sky and here
they used all these orbits all these
days 11 days
and came back with that and it was a
risky image
it was taken with hubble uh as taken
with
the institute director's discretionary
time
he has 20 of hubble time available to
him that he can use for anything
and he decided in one year to do this
and people were actually kind of mad at
him about it because
this was a risk why are we wasting
hubble for 11 days on nothing
yeah look at that no i don't think
there's a single image out there i don't
care who you are
that puts perspective on the cosmos
better than that one
yeah it's truly phenomenal and uh they
followed up the ultra deep field but
this yeah we call this you know
oftentimes the cosmos is wallpaper
let's see if this will work bro i'll get
some ad for some kind of blue colored
pills
that youtube knows i like okay let me
see if this will go full screen
there it is oh so now zooming in as tony
just said on this
microscopic region and every single
bit of light you're seeing tony right is
a is a galaxy not
there's one or two every stop smudge and
smear
in the double d field as a galaxy there
it is that's the ultra deep field there
um you can tell the difference because
it's it was taken with a
wide field camera uh too i think this
was
the region was taken with with pick two
all right so it's a different camera
but yeah that's it that's every single
thing in there is a galaxy
every single one just count them up
a trillion galaxies right
yeah depending on depending on the image
that one might have 11 000 in it um
the original hubble had like 5 000 6000
galaxies in it
um so let's see do we have a final image
to share yeah we do
okay so i can let's share my screen
zoom here again and um
very soon it's buried on my screen
somewhere
i've got too much i got to close up some
windows to find zoom i'm
zooming at adler ultra deep field
yeah yeah um
yeah this is my ultra deep field um yeah
it would be interesting uh
to have a image of the pillars of
creation done by hubble now maybe
samuel you could bring it up on the web
while you're doing that i could
uh in some ways that would be nice to
throw that first
and then maybe you could pull up a
bubble yeah
i got it i got it here okay and i was
thinking
while we're waiting for mike to get that
image up i'd love to have everyone
see what mike's observatory looks like
and the actual telescopes that he uses
to to take all these amazing images i
put together a little uh little
one and a half minute video that uh
highlights them that i could share with
everybody right now
yeah why aren't you sure all right you
guys can bring up those other ones
all right here we go
hey everybody samuel singer here the
founder and executive director of
wyoming stargazing
i'm here with the vice president of the
board of directors mike adler
and we're here at his house and his
incredible observatory
he's been helping us out doing some
virtual stargazing programs using his
telescopes in there
so we're going to go down and check it
out
the observatory is unusual because it's
a
it's called a clam shell and it totally
opens
and so you can have more than one
telescope in it
a normal observatory that you're
probably you see
in pictures has one telescope in the
middle
but this one i can have three telescopes
because it can be completely opened
so what we have here is the 20-inch
telescope
and uh it's uh it's about a bit of a
monster it weighs a
you know probably close to a couple
hundred pounds this
is my second largest telescope which i
use mostly for visual use
and also looking at the moon and the
planets
this telescope is my smallest but it's a
very useful telescope because a lot of
the objects in the sky the deep space
objects
we look at are quite large and some of
them are many times the size of the moon
and so you need a telescope like this to
get the so you can see the full field of
view
join us for virtual stargazing programs
via zoom
on new moon fridays uh throughout the
year
all right cool all right i'm gonna share
my screen
of the pillars of creation from hubble
and then we'll look at mike's
and then we'll be wrapping up and
tucking in with a
cup of hot cocoa at least in my case
so this is an image from video from
space
can you guys see that or is it frozen
so here's a kind of a tour through these
pillars of creation as they're called
and that's because
these are star forming regions and we
believe
that to have a planet that could host
the life
uh you need to be able to form certain
stars that have just the right
properties
to allow for life to form so to speak
so this is uh these pillars of creation
have
kind of become an iconic image that's
the most famous energy yeah that's
it right there let me see some light but
you can see that the
very complex fluid mechanics that's
taking place here as you have
boundary layers shock fronts elimination
tons and tons of dust and soot and so
forth that will
later become the seeds that generate
new new planets new solar systems
perhaps with them looking back at us and
you can see that
the kind of the inner shape here that
mike had shown before and now it's
zooming out to show the entirety of the
eagle nebula
uh and really this is the core this is
the interesting
very interesting region and then these
are other regions that hubble has imaged
i'm looking for uh allied phenomena
such as uh such as displayed here and
you saw the ferry over there on the left
that i was talking about earlier
yeah right here yeah
so great so let's look at mike okay now
it's not this
needless to say this is not uh my image
is not a hubble image
but it is uh i will uh i will share it
um it's a little less expensive
expectations managed
so here it is um hey that's amazing
yeah um so um it's pretty nice
and um blotchy i'll tell you that yeah
and uh so you know uh here's the ferry
and uh here
here it is and i can zoom in some on
this yeah
so you're seeing a lot of some of the
same structure you were just seeing
on the uh hubble uh these uh
patterns that are in this part of the uh
of the
of the pillar and uh as well as uh
um
up here so you know it doesn't have the
sharpness of the edges that the hubble
does
but uh i haven't seen in an amateur
photo
this much detail uh in uh in the fillers
yeah don't forget hubble is looking uh
directly at this object if you will
and um and here in uh jackson wyoming
you're looking through an atmosphere
even though you're at
about 6 000 plus feet you're still
looking through
you know 80 percent of the atmosphere
and the water vapor and turbulence to
get such an image it's just spectacular
and and that's why i wanted to share
with you this wonderful opportunity
i don't know i know that there are many
many great amateur
astronomers uh who take wonderful
astrophotographs
but i've never met somebody that can
take pictures like this and so i'm
really blown away as a
professional astronomer and i think
judging from tony's reaction and he too
can testify as a professional these are
really outstanding qualities so
we hope that tonight's been really
interesting
for all the viewers out there there are
hundreds watching in different channels
uh staying up late and i want to first
thank tony for co-hosting and
and giving us the insider's glimpse of
what it was like to uh to be a part of
some of this and processing some of
these and
being around space telescope yeah thank
you can i just ask you a quick question
brian somebody wants to know where that
link is to the
um some of that uh processing software
you were talking about but it was
this was from gen gen 7 um but i don't
know if it
if he's talking about the juno cam
software or just the processing software
that mike uses
uh did you post a link i posted i posted
a link to the juno
uh software earlier but um on your
on your on your on my stream yeah and my
live chat
okay and i just don't mind just maybe
emailing it to me i
i can't get to the okay all you really
have to do if you want to access those
photos is just to uh
uh junocam nasa or just juno
uh and you'll get to the nasa website
that's that's good yeah that's a good
idea i've got i'll post it again in my
chat now and i'll move to tony i'll go
to you
as well um so uh
sam you want to uh uh tell the unlucky
viewer
or you know watcher submitter who
is located in the united states we have
to be
uh cautious because it is very expensive
to ship outside of the country so
we had a bunch of people register for
this and i said there'd be some
giveaways
and i want to ask sam to give away or to
announce the winner and then
hopefully that person will be in the
united states uh and if not we can uh
we'll have to redraw another one but uh
stay tuned for that
um so sam you have a list of entrants
i do yeah i've got the list and then
we've got uh four
door prizes uh the first two are a
couple of wyoming stargazing stickers
made by some uh
maybe not share your screen so we can
see it better okay sure
yeah is that uh i'll stop here that's my
screen yeah
there we go all right yeah thank you so
yeah
a couple a couple stickers maybe by some
local artists here in jackson holly sage
art um we've got a uh
the last remaining wyoming stargazing
kendama
this is the last one that's ever going
to be made so if you walk away with this
it's
it's going to be a collector's item and
then brian mentioned earlier
um the grand prize door prize
is this uh incredible print of the
elephant trunk nebula
that mike made with his uh his
telescopes
so we'll get some names drawn here i'm
just uh
spinning a pen on the list of names and
we'll just see where the pen points
okay i even made the frame to that
picture
oh nice okay so the uh the winner of the
uh the first eclipse
sticker is chris munson
chris if you're in the u.s please this
is uh not only in the us he's in san
diego
in miami all right because he is my uh
co-worker on the simon's observatory
congratulations chris and i didn't have
anything to do with it
trust me uh-huh yeah come on
here comes for the second sticker
we've got uh brian christie
for this uh this sticker right here
brian if you're in the u.s just uh put a
quick note in the uh the chat for us so
we know
all right so now for the kendama
we've got christopher ellis
another one of my employees actually now
he's a graduate student in
reno nevada university of nevada arena
congratulations these chris's that work
in my lab they're super successful
all right i promise i'm just spinning
this pen and it's just
well i did get the vote out i mean i i
did
all right so here's for the uh the grand
prize for mike's print
and we've got brianna jimenez
congratulations brianna
so brian just um you can uh you can send
an email to
info at wyomingstargazing.org with your
address and we'll get that print to you
well guys i want to thank you all so
much this has been super fun
yeah uh i hope it's been the value we
had a little technical difficulties but
that's been the norm in the last couple
of a
couple of months uh in zoom land tapping
all the bandwidth that we were using and
so that combined with forest fires covet
attacks et cetera
looking out i can never predict what's
going to go wrong when i start a stream
these days it's just
what things that work forever just stop
working and i'm like what
uh it happens one minute before you hit
the go live button
so sorry one of my friends says this
this is proof that we're living in a
simulation because
everything that's going wrong can go
wrong um i want to thank you i want to
encourage people to please join wyoming
stargazing donate
it's the 501c3 organization if you're
ever in jackson
you must take advantage of it it's one
of the most
exciting things to see next to having a
moose chase after you
you will uh you'll never forget your
observation through their gigantic
telescopes and who knows you might be
able to meet one of the best if not the
best
amateur astrophotographer in the world
michael adler thank you so much that was
some nice work mike that was amazing
stuff thanks for sharing yeah
so we hope to do this more leave some
comments on tony's channel my channel
if you guys want to see more of this i'm
hoping to do another one before the end
of the year while it's still the 30th
anniversary year of hubble space
telescopes launch
and also the 100th anniversary of the
great debate so i've been having all
these debates
okay brian you've been talking what what
what debate i don't know what you mean
the great debate what was that
so they called 1920 they called the what
was later called the great debate was
the curtis shapley debate the famous
curtis shapley debate
over the size of the milky way galaxy
and the existence of extra galactic
objects such as uh what was later called
the indra
first called the andromeda nebula but
then is now known as the great galaxy
and the great andromeda galaxy so these
took place in washington dc
and if you look up the curtis shapley
debates this is harlow
shapley and heber curtis
and these were uh the first of us not
the first
in my mind they're just one of many
debates as to whether or not the
universe is centered
on the earth they are human beings in
some sense or another either in time or
in space
and this was uh what's really captivated
the
nation's attention uh for a while in
1920 so
that being the case we want to celebrate
that that
discovery with the also concomitant
discoveries that have taken place since
then
so hopefully we're in the midst of a of
another renaissance of astronomy
and uh everybody out there listening
watching all over the world
uh i want to thank you all for tuning in
tony
thank you for co-hosting sam and michael
good night keep looking up stay safe
and tune in next time for our next
virtual stargate i don't know if this
has ever happened before so this is kind
of cool
explains why we had some technical
difficulties but nevertheless
uh keep in touch everybody and uh please
join deep astronomy
and please join wyoming stargazing and
contribute
is um this it can do we say how to get a
hold of all the wyoming stargazing
i put some on the link in the chat i'll
put some in the in the description box
as well
there's also at wi stargazing on
instagram i think
is there uh is the way to answer okay
yeah
i'll put all those links all that in
there
and it was a pleasure meeting you guys
and mike amazing work man a great great
setup you've got there too that's an
amazing observatory
thank you it's really spectacular so
thank you everybody have a wonderful
night
thanks everybody tony thank you so much
brian thank you